[Music]
days after sustaining severe injuries in
an accident zoe zozo bethel who was
crowned miss alabama for america strong
in 2021 has died she was 27 years old
the former model and political
correspondent's family confirmed the sad
news on monday revealing she died on
february 18 after succumbing to her
injuries her family adds that she
touched the hearts of many and included
a gofundme link where fans can donate to
support burial and medical expenses
before asking that their privacy be
respected at this difficult time and
while few details about the accident
have been made public we do know bethel
was living and working in miami at the
time of her death
bethel's family first revealed that she
had been injured on february 16th
explaining that she had been involved in
an accident on february 10 sustained
severe damage to her brain and was in a
coma
unfortunately the doctors are saying the
damage cannot be repaired and that she
may not have much time left
this has been an abrupt and very
traumatizing situation for our family
and we can imagine how much of a shock
this will also be to everyone who knows
and cares for her
my advice for the girls out there
especially if you're interested in the
fashion industry don't be afraid to
express who you are i mean whatever you
might believe i mean that's we're in
america that's your yes you're right uh
but i mean still to stay professional uh
stay respectful
to other people and their beliefs but i
mean don't be afraid to
to speak out whenever you express or the
times that you express who you are
a blessing will still come out of it
following the news of her death friends
and former colleagues paid honor to
bethel on social media grace saldana the
editor-in-chief of right-side
broadcasting network tweeted in part
quote besides the fact that she was
always incredibly stunning i'll always
remember how convicted zoe was in her
faith in god how dedicated she was to
her beliefs and protecting life and how
much she cared for others may she rest
in peace
if you are true to who you are
and if you stand by your beliefs like
god will still he'll end up blessing you
for it
the miss alabama america organization
added that the world lost a queen
writing quote she was a light in this
world and we are heartbroken over the
loss of such a bright and beautiful
woman rest in grace and love sweet one
you